hi my name is Vincent I will talk to you
today about the pet project of mine
called tech names as a service it's kind
of a sort of a hobby project and I will
basically explain how this Hobbit
project came to be the math behind it is
actually more interesting than you might
think
now you might be wondering Who am I my
name is Vincent I've been working for
three years over the company called go
to this ribbon you might also know me
from my blog Koenig on Io I'm the chair
of Pattaya Amsterdam I'm a preferred
trading partner for our CTO and
Amsterdam I host the machine learning
meet up I give free sessions in open
data next week I get to give a Python
course to a but I think thirty Syrian
refugees which going to be awesome also
I've got 39 endorsements for Awesomeness
on my LinkedIn profile basically a media
consultant I do dated stuff one the main
features of my LinkedIn profile is this
picture of me in a ball pit and was a
Pokemon shaped atop and I call myself
Pokemon master I would hope that this
would deter recruiters on my LinkedIn
profile but this is not the case to
emphasize even more with my LinkedIn
profile is like this is the keyword
bingo that I post on it I will leave you
to sort of check it out and hopefully
you understand the joke because this is
how the whole thing started if you look
carefully you'll see things like Python
and JavaScript and shiny and deep liar
and / and low - and Vulpix I typically
ask recruiters to point out which of
these are Pokemon turns out it's very
very hard for a recruiter to know
difference between a Pokemon and a Big
Data technology so you know I am kind of
mean but I do think it's kind of
ridiculous if you're trying to offer me
the best job ever that you don't know
the difference we Metapod and unity
thing I think so that's basically where
all this started I started noticing that
hey recruiters really have a bad time
doing this and it's actually kind of a
fun game I play with the cruisers online
I'm kind of a mean person and I should
really play them too much because
there's this other if you get if you go
in github there's this repo called repo
c'mon and basically it's all the github
projects out there they're named after
Pokemon so the recruiters aren't even
wrong when they think it's a big dinner
technology there's actually something
called guilty on or something called
Gollum etc anyway fun fact but the main
idea I had was hey apparently there's
some truth in that pokemons names sound
like big data
and I can imagine if your hip startup in
Silicon Valley then you probably need a
good name and if you can use Pokemon is
a nice corporates to start from actually
that might be a nice app let's sort of
make an app that makes names that sound
like Pokemon it's with the seemed like
an interesting idea and this has kind of
got me on this adventure for a fun and
profit so this is the end product that I
want to make it will have some sort of
web app that will generate names in your
behalf preferably to sound like Pokemon
but maybe other things as well so the
task at hand then is given a sequence of
tokens can we generate a sequence of
tokens that is different but believably
similar so it has to be a different
pokemons name but it has a sound as if
it's a pokemons name and these are
things like you know Pokemon obviously
things have two Pokemon as a nice
example but if you think about it
relativity / lyrics also kind of fall
into that you have these words that
royalty peppers use in their lyrics you
might also be able to generate lyrics
that sound as if the Red Hot Chili
Peppers could have written them IKEA
furniture names I think it's also an
excellent example for lots of this notes
on the piano also fall into this
category if you're playing notes in a
certain melody in a certain tune in a
certain chord with a certain style also
that I can see is a sequence of tokens
that you should be able to generate so
there's kind of a common task and
anything Epsom basically works this way
as well so this is the formal task that
I'm going to try to tackle I will now
have to probably re-enter my Wi-Fi
password I'm gonna give you a quick demo
of the web app you can already play with
it it's on tonascar tech names as a
service comm if you can connect to the
Wi-Fi you should be able to play with it
it's version 0.1 don't expect too much
of it and the whole point of the app is
to find a better name for it the
features that I have is you can select
the corpus so the idea is you should be
able to say hey I want to have something
that sounds like a pokemon or IKEA name
or Esperanto or whatever you should be
able to select the model and then click
go and it will generate a name for you
but as a bonus feature and this was sort
of the main thing that I found out was
the coolest thing what might be even
better is if you then say don't generate
the entire Pokemon name but I want to
have I want to make a new hipster
database company it has to have three
characters to the unknown but has to end
with bass generate the first three
tokens for me
this is sort of the main feature of the
website that are able to do this you're
kind of being able to give me a sort of
reg X and I'm going to make it sound as
if it's a Pokemon by filling in the
stars that you've given me and this
makes the problem
easier and harder so let's do a quick
demo and do a way of the cats this is
the website and I now have to make sure
the Wi-Fi works so I will double check
if the Wi-Fi is still working it is
still working so the idea is a landing
page and I remind you of all the things
that you could be naming things like
World of Warcraft guild or a NASA rocket
the idea is we didn't give you this red
X - this little robot and we are going
to make profit for you now this is the
whole app I can click generate a bunch
of times and it's going to in this case
give me some Pokemon names things that
sound like Pokemon obviously the length
of the Pokemon name is still an issue
and then we get to the outer complete
step I'll explain why this is slower but
the idea is when you generate this it's
going to make things that sort of sound
like a Pokemon so if I were now to say
I'm going to have a hipster start of it
ends with Lee maybe hustla knuckly
that's not a good one Emily Cheerilee
okay crowd participation any takers
sorry sorry float seed like the Angela C
busy Jeezy fully ELISA reasonably
sounding like a Pokemon and the main
gist is also kind of cool is I can be
very flexible with this so if I wanted
to start with a D and end with another
token I should be able to generate this
on the fly not everything is as good but
this is what the app is supposed to do
it should be able to fill in the blanks
this is kind of nice because this allows
a user to give me more data to actually
have less entropy for the poke of our
name whereas if I had to start from here
and the so there's lots of possibilities
to go from and here the user gives me
input I have to use that input but then
the improv actually helped me get a
better Pokemon it this is the main thing
I'm trying to build and mathematically
that'll turn out to be actually kind of
tricky
but we get the idea behind the app is we
have supposed to do I'm and then you
know hopefully for the future what's
probably going to happen is that there's
going to be a button here that says buy
domain name and I'll make dozens of
euros this works like I was told today
that there's like companies that
specialize in making a name for a
company these are like the marketing
films and stuff I'm totally going to
disrupt with industry
the hope I guess let's talk about the
machine learning because I thought that
was sort of the interesting part because
the moment you think of this hey with
the generative sequence of tokens the
first thing you think of is hey that's a
Markov chain we basically have to
calculate given the letter that you have
now what's the probability for the next
letter sample that letter move on move
on move on etcetera the simple idea you
should be able to just be able to do
this first and you can make them more
complicated instead of saying let's do
one step back
you might also be able to say hey let's
look two steps back so the previous two
characters that define the new per
character I'm going to get and if we're
going to sample you first need to sample
the first token then you distribution to
get the second token from that point on
you keep going and going and going
that's the idea if you think about it
though you don't have to do it forward
you can also conjure up any sort of
chain if you want that just point in all
sorts of different directions you are
not limited by just a forward Markov
chain every article you see here is
basically a probability distribution and
yes I might be learning these
probabilities and they'll be slightly
different here but the shape of the
graph is something that's independent so
you can still sample anyway or for when
I show you this I also hope you kind of
have an impression that we still have an
issue that we have to solve and that is
can anyone guess what the issue is if I
want to generate a pokemons name why am
I not done yet Markov chains will go on
forever that's the whole point of a
Markov chain that's sort of infinite a
pokemons name typically is finite if I
look at the sample I have so I first
need to come up with a nice way that
says hey how long is the pokemons name
and and also short Pokemon names they
might have different letters that start
with different things the easy trick you
can do is you can sort of apply you know
Bayesian statistics and you can just say
well first I'm going to sample the
length of the token little the length of
the sequence at least and from then on
I'll just apply the Markov chain that's
a thing you could do but I hope you
already kind of realize that this is a
bit naive but a neat thing is I it's a
very short poking my name I'm probably
gonna use different letters and it was a
very long Pokemon name so whatever I'm
doing probablistic here I'm always still
modeling I would like to have this
entropy to find better but I my model is
still somewhat naive it might feel be
good though so I just figured out let's
just try this approach the simple Markov
chain I say we get and not all results
are bad I
really think you till could have been a
Pokemon LED tips typically probably
isn't a very good Pokemon name I don't
like the fact that there's two to three
letters that aren't vowels Keane is cool
I guess is cool but but it's not
completely there yet when doing is for
Pokemon obviously you also do it for
IKEA furniture and I really really hope
I'm going to buy a fro dog couch someday
or the VIS television set or the uh napa
meatballs or what have you and this is
all kind of fun and this sort of works
horse I'm not super long my favorite one
is just the red chili-pepper lyrics
because when you read this I actually
feel that it's somewhat plausible that
it is indeed the drug-induced lyrics
from this one of my favorite bands one
thing you do see for example is the now
I'm sampling words by the way enough
characters too we have emphasized that
but when things like by the way occur
super super often in a song called by
the way and then obviously by the way
will also return in things your sample
the downside is everything I'm doing
here as well is to be my sample as the
size is not big I don't have all the
names of the United States I have 700 or
so Pokemon names and maybe one or so
write a chili pepper song so whatever I
do I have to keep in mind that my sample
size is kind of small actually
accommodate that which actually also
make this problem rather hard so I hope
I've explained the model is a bit naive
and results could be better and also
I've done the Markov chain explanation
but I've not explained yet how do you
deal with known characters for unknown
characters that part that feature I've
not explained fully yet but I had but I
didn't notice hey you know I might be
able to do something better so what are
some alternatives I could consider well
for one you could maybe build ensemble
that usually works that's what we
learned from random forests if I have a
way of sort of I start with the first
token now to generate the second token
this generates a probability
distribution I can do that for all three
generators probability distributions and
then average those probability
distributions and then sample probably
that's a bit less naive I kind of like
the idea that instead of forward
sampling I may be able to do backward
sampling and have those two things have
an opinion on what's happening another
alternative is I can actually use
different Mexicans for example what I
could do is I could say hey here's a
Pokemon and I've
model for that but I also have maybe the
English language that way I can kind of
force with a similar idea that I had
here but by using a second language of
the second model I might be able to
force that my Pokemon names sound
English and therefore might actually be
better in terms of owls in consonants
and you might think that's a crazy idea
but turns out that what you could also
do the French translate everything
including pokemons names
Pikachu is the only Pokemon that is not
translated in the French language in
France Snorlax is called the whole flex
mouth it's called meows you could also
do that but then I would probably use a
different corpus another thing you could
do is you could use the tender
transducer trick where you would say hey
I've got this normal Pokemon the data
said I have and have a model for it what
I can also do then is I can say hey
let's make a separate Markov chain that
does something for vowels and non vowels
and makes a Markov chain out of that and
that's sort of a map phase you do before
and then you can still do the ensemble
trick but this will definitely prevent
that you see four vowels in a row also
something I could consider I call so
kind of go for the adverse early
approach you know yet you just have a
model that says this is probably a fake
Pokemon or a real one you can make a
classifier that does that then you have
your generators generate a hundred
samples or so and have the other
algorithm pick the best one of them
might also be not a bad idea what you
can also do is you can kind of take a
levenshtein approach you start with a
Pokemon that you already have and then
you say randomly pick a letter and we're
going to change that letter the H
changes into an R next you see the a
change in 200 then this Oh change to e
the R change to a B again and this P
changes into a k if unit is often enough
and depending on what this this is
better you use it's also kind of
possible as you come up with a Pokemon
name that sounds reasonable
what I like about this I'm not
necessarily doing anything complex here
and I can take any sort of distance
measure that I want once I found out
about yesterday there's this thing
called chart effect so what you actually
can do is you can make character
embeddings and that way you could say
hey if I'm replacing an O with an e if I
use the English language I can use this
distance between characters to say how
likely it is to sample this letter if
you replace it also not a bad idea but
then of course all of my peers at the PI
data say all what you do is you totally
go for deep learning that's like the
best thing you can do obviously with 700
Pokemon names this is deep learning
obviously it's going to be better
there's papers and blogs and everything
and here is sort of a moment where I
went to wait hold on
let's just stop because deep learning
will never work for my second use case I
think I'll gladly hear if I'm mistaken
here but I've asked it to a bunch of
professors always turns out to be a
hilarious conversation if you're having
this conversation with the professor my
ultimate goal is I like to sample a
Pokemon name but my ultimate goal is to
complete one and when I have this one
example where I have a star a you a star
and an a or a you a star in a I hope
it's super obvious that given all of
these characters together this should
not be a vowel it should be a consonant
it should be the K or an L but it
shouldn't be an E now typically these
neural network models they work via some
sort of you have a star token is sample
a letter and you keep on sampling
utility we just stop token but what I
kind of need here is I need a
bi-directional way of going and also
there might be knowns and unknowns in
there and already I hope you might be
able to do it alike a bi-directional LCM
and you might be able to fill in some of
the letters but again this is a hobby
project no way is that the path forward
you might may still be able to do it but
you're going to have to hack a lot so I
figured let's drop deep learning
straight from here and how about I just
go for simple algorithms instead it
might just be good enough and to be very
honest I first started this project
thinking I only need to generate Pokemon
names but when I started playing with
the idea you can actually give more
information as a user that's also the
moment when I started noticing that
people actually said hey this app is
actually getting better it wasn't so
much a change in algorithm or the change
in the user interface that actually made
the app better in terms of user
experience better machine learning
doesn't always lead to a better feature
it was also a nice lesson I learned from
doing this so how have I solved this
then the way I did it is I basically
said you can look at this as a Markov
chain another way of looking at it to
say this is a publicity crackle model
and if the usually gives me input that
these are the characters that I need
then already I know the shapes are the
length of all the nodes in my prolific
graph and let's say the fact that I know
the probability to get from here to here
that doesn't mean I cannot do inference
from here to here if I know the
probability that if I roll a certain
number of dice the sum of the eyes will
be a certain number if I know that
probability but I can also infer that
given the number of eyes what dice have
I rolled the inference can work both
ways if you only know one of the
probabilities so you can just apply that
here and even though I wouldn't directly
sample this one first what I would do is
I would just sample let's say this one
then I will sample the oh I know these
probabilities because I inferred them
from here then I sample the next one and
then I sample the next one and it
doesn't matter what shapes I have I can
have multiple probabilistic graphical
shapes but the inference always works
the same way you basically say given
these things in probably a graphical
model Bayes rule what is the likelihood
of this token now you can do this for
every single node in this graph
I don't like building a tool that does
this though I like it'll be like a
separate machine learning library that
needs to do this so will be kind of nice
if that already exists in a Python
ecosystem if you're going to do
something like this I have advice for
you there's a library called Markova
fine basically you feel any interval
with strings and it will actually build
a Markov chain on it that's the simple
version that will have a start token the
stop token oldest generated for you our
goal Phi is nice for that one use case
for the advanced use case where I'm
using this I prefer to use a library
called pomegranate the best way to
describe pomegranate is basically this I
could learn but all the stuff that's
missing from Sai could learn if you're a
bit more of a Bayesian it's usually in
pomegranate it's the great machine
learning library it has little Markov
chains it has a nice API that's kind of
Sai could learn like but a lot of these
things that make this use case super
easy is slowly because of that library
it's building size things pretty fast
and I really really love it you can
build public graphical models with
discrete variables with great ease the
weight of the code sort of looks like is
you have to import it and then you say
here all the pokemon names this is how
far I'm willing to look back and then
it's going to chain a train a Markov
chain now a Markov chain actually only
has a few distributions namely how do
you get from the first token to the
second and how do you get from the first
and second token to the third let's say
if you look back of three you then have
these distributions and you can get them
out of your Markov chain if you want to
if you train these distributions and
with the only thing you have to do then
is you have to say okay given these
train distributions make a new like it
inference time make a new Bayesian
network add the states which are all the
tokens you could sample and although the
societal probably distributions that I
have here
bake the network and then give me the
probabilities given the things that I do
know what's the probability of all the
other tokens pomegranate will just do
this all of this will I just explained
with these seven lines of code I don't
want to do a tutorial and pomegranate
I'm pretty sure you guys can read the
documents yourself but please take a
library out it's a super cool library it
should and um focus should support it
it's one of the best things out there
also the guy that made it this name is
Jacob he's a cool dude send material
given high-five okay so I hope I got the
math bit right so I hope we have an
impression why we like this
probabilistic graphical models and it's
kind of flexible but then I have to push
this live and the thing with this is it
is kind of a practical joke of projects
I do I'm I'm going to joke that I'm
going to make dozens of euros but I
don't but it's probably just going to be
something I can point to and laugh at I
don't want to spend dozens of euros on
this per month
preferably I don't have some sort of
server that's going to be able to handle
all the traffic but let's say I spent 10
euros a month that's still 10 euros a
month there's a hundred euros a year for
a guy project is actually kind of a lot
of money I actually want to have more of
these projects so I need to come up with
a nice way to do this in the chief with
fashion let's first make an observation
though because technically what I've
just done is I've trained a machine
learning model and typically a state a
scientist when we have a machine
learning model that does a certain task
we like we want to push that to
production so also this task is rather
general so let's take a step back and
consider the general situation typically
when you have a machine learning model
let's say you do a linear regression you
are calculating let's say the price of a
house based on the area of the of the
house the number of bedrooms and number
of square meters etc well sure you have
to train this and then you have a number
for this parameter and for that
parameter so but once you've trained all
of that the resulting function that you
used to predict is a lambda function if
you put the same numbers in the same
numbers come out it'll never change is a
stateless function so you don't need a
stateful server to push this to
production if you think about it the
only thing I need is a service that just
allows this one function
be live I think this is a it's not so
there are models where you do want every
data point it comes in the function
updates but anything from scikit-learn
has this property it's stateless and
that's actually kind of a powerful
notion any trained machine learning
model is proportional to a lambda
technically this isn't a perfect lambda
function because I'm using the random
state of the machine so mutants it's not
super stateless but stateless enough to
prove the point that machine learning
models typically are very stateless so
any service that allows me to provision
stateless functions will be awesome so
let's do the super naive implementation
this is the function I want to have live
and this is a super naive implementation
because I'm in this one function I'm
also doing the training I'm using
Markova Phi to train the Pokemon names
and then generate a random one and then
send that back but technically all of
that is just in this bit of code I have
all my Pokemon names I'm turning it into
a list because that's what Michael if I
wants I'm making a chain of it and then
I'm saying okay make this text and the
sex model just do a random walk return
that this is a lander function that can
generate the content that I want for my
website let's say in the simple case
right this is the simple use case
scenario I just explain this the idea
then is is there's this service on
Amazon called lambda it's sort of we
have servers then we have VMs that we
have docker and now the idea is you
don't provision a server in a docker
container you just say this is a
function just run this function in the
cloud for me please so what I will show
you now is how to provision like your
first hello world helpers in this AWS
such as you have a rest endpoint that
can generate random Pokemon names
well the first thing that you have to do
is you have to like Amazon doesn't know
all your dependencies from hard so what
you have to do is you have to make sure
that all the dependencies that you have
go to Amazon that are provisioning a
function it needs all these dependencies
so what you need to do is you have to
pip install the library that you want
but saving it in a separate path such
that you can zip that this both the
library and your own function such that
together can go to Amazon now this is a
sake because we're going to click a lot
now you go to Amazon you'll get to this
screen this is something called API
gateway to lambda you're going to click
a few buttons clickety click click click
click and then you're going to say
there's a lambda microservice it's going
to be on production clickety click click
click click click click you're going to
upload the zip file though the coating
is told you about you're going to name
your function you're going to describe
that it does a super useful Pokemon task
you can also say which run time it is
because you can do stuff in Python but
also node I believe when I did this they
only had Python 2.7 thankfully now we
can do 3.6 as well which is cool click
lick lick lick lick lick lick lick we've
just written a function but the function
needs to be hooked up to the internet so
you're going to click around a bunch
more then the idea is you have to say
hey you should be able to get to this
Pokemon names end point and you can have
versioning and all that but you can only
get it by get requests so the way you
access the lambda function there's all
sorts of provisioning for that as well
note that a lambda function can also be
triggered by let's say a change in s3
it's not just web requests that trigger
the function other stuff as well but in
my main use case I just want a person
who's on my you know page say hey slash
I want to generate a Pokemon named ping
ping back and ping one thing you might
want to do is hint because this will go
wrong if you don't do it one of the
things you can then also set is
something like a course header the
course header says only people that go
to ten ask comm slash API only those
people can get to the data otherwise
people with a simple curl request can
also get there there are some security
settings you probably want to set here
as well I'm going to repeat this later
because it's super important that you
know this but there's extra settings you
can do here too once you've done all
this you done the clicking clicking
here's the features that Amazon tells
you that you have supposedly you get the
first 1 million requests for free
depending on how often the function is
used the latency I I typically get tends
to be able to hundred milliseconds you
can like have a function that has more
resources and then it's kind of quicker
but ok
without any settings I kind of have
between 200 milliseconds in a second
the response time not bad but I would
like to maybe improve that apparently
supposedly it's only 20 cents for every
next million or so and I think nowadays
it's 10 cents per million and requests
supposedly I don't have to worry about
scaling Amazon will do this for me it's
relatively easy to update if you think
about it but it's a bit of an immature
architecture so it's just a function so
I can push that to get but I probably
want to automate a bunch of steps that I
have right now one thing I will say this
is obviously a cloud login if you do
this on Amazon this way
note that Google at the moment doesn't
have Python support yet and I don't like
Windows so you're probably stuck with
Amazon if you gotta go down this route
the thing that's actually kind of nice
is then you know obviously I would like
to compare this to let's say a 10 euro
flask server like how does this compare
10 minutes got it and let's say this
fast server it can handle on a request
per second well suppose that I have on a
request per second and I have like a
high um requests per second for eight
hours a day or so lemma function is
actually still a fair bit cheaper these
days so it is kind of a contender and
the idea behind this is if I don't use
the lambda function because it's a hobby
project I pay zero only when a lot of
people end up using it that's when I pay
now that's the super useful for my use
case but it will say for other
production tasks it's actually kind of
cool because typically when you apply a
machine learning model that's when you
start earning money usually you apply it
to get money in return this way it
doesn't cost you anything if you're not
making extra money so that there is some
economic benefit that could be had here
I'm not sure how much I like the logging
and debugging though this is another
function that's now live it's something
I have to maintain and what I haven't
talked about yet is how I do logging on
a lambda function like this what I
haven't talked about is how you debug
something like this because you still
need to do a bit of engineering here you
probably do want to push some output to
elasticsearch or kibana
or something that amazon offers and for
your front-end you still probably want
to have something like sentry to keep an
eye on the errors that you get back from
your function you still need to do a
fair bit of engineering but there are
some nice things each again bit of
warning I did this for my first time and
then my website went down Amazon can go
down so I think two months ago it went
down and the first thing I always do
when a website goes down I go to the
website is it down today calm the
downside is is it down to date of calm
is hosted on s3 so that website was down
the internet responded by saying there's
this other website is is it down today
down today calm
that website is now also down this joke
is an obvious joke but is he really to
remind you cloud services can fail it's
super infrequent but when it does things
go bad and you in this situation you
cannot just say ok same server go to
boof other region it's a little bit more
tricky tonight you still have
contingency planning you might want to
be mindful of so I just talked about
this also this function you might want
to have some authentication layer I
haven't talked about that yet maybe only
if you log in do you get access to this
machine learning model and also we have
to automate a bunch of this stuff
another thing that's kind of useful to
remember if you have a 10 euro flask
server and you get a DDoS attack sure
the server will go down but you're not
going to pay more for it if you're going
to get a DDoS attack Amazon was skill
horizontally on your behalf
so there are throttling and stuff that
you can do Amazon is there to help you
as well but these are things you have to
be kind of aware of it's not a free
lunch and I can't have to go over stuff
so quickly so how many requests do you
need to get pwned like let's say pwned
by definition is if I have spent $1,000
in a month then the guy or girl that's
hacking you really only need to spend
3800 requests a second that is
manageable like people can own you this
way so throttle keep it in mind now
let's do this a bit more maturely I'll
go over this relatively fast because I
want to have some time for questions we
ought to automate some of this stuff and
talk about some of the downsides of this
because right now I've uploaded a simple
library that has no real dependencies
but if you're going to do something
which I could learn this uploading to
Amazon step is actually a bit more
complicated a few more things you have
to know you notice that one of the
functions I use that generated the
normal Pokemon and the one that had
completed the completed Pokemon took
longer to return a value
the idea behind lambda function is
they're not always live the concept is
if this one function is after 5 minutes
no longer being used Amazon sort of
kills the container that the function is
being run in five minutes basically to
prevent costs from going sky-high remind
yourself you might want to have a cron
job that queries this endpoint just
ensure that the function is always hot
a thing to be mindful of you can do cool
stuff where you say hey let's do an API
design because I have a model and a
corpus and complete that and you can
sort of two nice frameworks here you can
also abstract things away which is nice
I will say what I have been using is the
first example that I showed we train
this function while you run it or
ideally he would cache this what I have
actually done is I cashed it in every
single lambda function so I've built a
command line app that bakes a function
for me and you have a Markov model for
Pokemon that's a separate function to me
that seems like the easiest way to cache
this stuff just have many different
lambda functions if it's not necessarily
the easiest way to maintain it but
otherwise you will need to provision a
database to do this caching for you this
picture because I'm working on my own a
bit of advice I will give to automate a
lot of this configuration why not make
your own command line app it's been the
most sane way for me to deal with a lot
of these things because I have to make a
command line app that can take all the
data they have train the model and then
push live either I can automate this
with all sorts of internal scripts but
actually because I like to be hacky and
also pass credentials the right way it's
not too bad as an idea to just build a
Python app that does this and if you use
an app called fire it's actually kind of
fun to do it really brings back the joy
in making command line app so this is a
preview I've got to last learn I can say
generate whole models and based on the
folder where my text files are it
generates all of this it keep it saying
automate all of this and keep it in git
it's also kind of nice be mindful if
you're going to do something which I
could learn this will by cue Amazon uses
its own docker container to run your
stuff and if using numpy it needs blasts
and blasts compiled differently on my
Mac than on that container so the whole
zipping up the code thing needs to
happen on their docker container not
your machine keep this in mind there's a
toriel's online there's actually a full
tutorial here I will go over it but it's
in the slides it's already on the github
skip skip skip if you're going to
automate this I will still use a command
line app but there are also levels of
abstraction these days that you can use
if you're doing this there's a thing
called code star where Amazon controls
your github repository but every time
you push to Bastyr there's a build step
the test step and then I push the
production staff at Amazon hand
for you super nice but vendor lock-in
there's another project called chalice
also by Amazon it's an easy way to get
your Python lemma functions to
production also lock-in there's another
project called Zappa and they're less of
the vendor lock-in and what they try to
do is they want to make sure that you
can do this both to Google once they
start having Python as well as Amazon if
I were you I'd pick for Zappa seems more
open source and cool and there are other
cloud services out there Google probably
will have lambda functions for Python I
cannot imagine they're going to stick
with node Azure I guess also have it but
I have a mega hard issue with Microsoft
the personal history I've never got that
lab stuff to work properly and so will
take a lot of time for me to convince me
to go to Europe but they do have Python
it says on the website so it might be
true in conclusion and I kind of had to
go over quickly because I want to have
some functions as up some questions
lambda cloud functions are actually kind
of cool it's a good idea for machine
learning practitioners to just say train
machine learning model cloud done skills
horizontally you don't have to be the
death of sky always still kind of have
to be it but let's show them before
servers have out so server can fill in
multiple ways and you might be
responsible for it this is a service
from lambda and it's super cheap there
is a lot of lock-in
but I think you can do either AWS or
Google cloud having said that you could
usually also just provision the server
right so this is a whole big project I
want the cost of below if you're doing
this on your own
provisioning a flask server might also
be a way to solve this
you don't need lambda it's just an
alternative for you guys one thing I
will say give publicity graphical models
a chance if you've never done anything
with publicity graphical models this
would have been a hard task if you have
done something with relegates
probablistic graphical models this task
takes five minutes
I really think deep learning algorithm
would not be feasible here almost a
graphical models are easy to design
there is to the bug there is it to
deploy and these are all things that I
care for thanks
those are things bins and grates out
just in time so we have five six minutes
for questions I thank very much for this
very entertaining and interesting talk
you're welcome I have one quick question
at the 200 milliseconds hot deployment
execution time for lambda function how
much of that was your code running and
how much if they were said Wow um so in
this particular case I'm also training
right so that hat doesn't help but so
what you can do is you can fiddle around
with the resources and the function is
in a dark container which has resources
and typically I think it has a certain
amount of megabytes RAM certain CPU etc
you can put more stuff in there the
lambda color function is will cost a bit
more but that could have the time easy
if we've done some experience with that
well the cool thing as well is if you
put more resources in a lambda function
the code runs quicker which means you
pay less per function there's there's
optimization I haven't touched upon
definitely you can make a quicker just
quick one about the length of the
Pokemon name yes why didn't you simply
act like spaces to the characters in
your Markov chain so a pokemons name
currently usually only has one name no
no no no I mean like I could just set
spaces to the possible characters and
then just break after space fair but
that you can also use a stop and end
token for that right so you could all
say we start with your sample the star
token then the first letter you continue
on until you sample a stop token but
that's also an approach you could do I
found though that for generating normal
poker my name's this approach would work
but there's many alternatives I just
want to do the simple thing first I
actually found that the use case where
the user supplies me the letters they
actually want that gives the best user
experience so that's the main use case
I'm focusing on but definitely you can
improve stuff this way that's that's
fair call
a very nice project I have a question
why not just taking your initial very
simple idea of
with this Markov chains yes define loss
function on the outcome yeah and how do
I value it so it's easy to say just to
find a loss function
the problem here is I only have 700 or
so Pokemon names so whatever lost firms
like them up with will also be biased
due to my small data set size yes when
your trend model also biased so I have
done some experience with this but more
for the adversarial approach and the
results were like modestly hardly
noticeably better hmm
like I would show it to my colleagues
never say fits into the same rubbish
okay maybe I will ask later okay should
honest I'm open to any suggestions to
this again the main use case though that
I have found and it's also kind of like
the joy it's not so much the machine
learning it's the entire use case if you
can put in your own let's say three
letters it has to end with base com base
and Slee base and the foo base that's a
great library for a database written in
JavaScript or could fetch a whatever
it's that one use case that I found out
that people actually like to play with
so that's the thing I'm optimizing for
this other use case I guess is cute but
this is of course just a random random
Markov chain not super this is the main
use case I really care for just thanks a
lot and one aside there's a German more
legendary hoster they do virtual service
you get one with ten gig of space for
one year or a month ok that's not bad
and if you want to push it remain on
that you can do that the only thing you
don't get a stalker because then you
would have super user rights on the
server and they don't give you that so
the just as a note for ya and so I'm
looking at these services as well
there's also another service called
hyper where you have daughter
entertainers that only contain like 46
gigs of RAM in megabytes around the main
thing with Amazon though is I do want to
have a cloud provider that should I need
it has support for s3 and I love these
other services they have like an issue
is case but not the general all the
other stuff just to plug them they are
called uber space they are called uber
space dot de da ze over space dot te
yes and and so I've ever like uber and
space as in space de
I will serve it on camera so that's good
we've clearly plug them twice I think
that's fine you have a question is it
about uber space - you know it's about
Deb function Oh a feeling it's not gonna
be a question but sure no is when will
your righteous - a because Amazon one
thing is it changes quickly so you write
all this then in December step functions
come and in February price in three six
came and so are you trying to keep it up
to date well that's also why I like
having the command line up because the
way I like to write software it's kind
of like Legos if there's one block in
the chain somewhere that changed I just
need to change in one block so if the
service provider changes I don't have to
redo the way I train my models it's
still the same command line app to me
this seems like the most sane way of
dealing with it I mean I can also train
a deep learning model to try to predict
with Amazon's going to do but I think
that's more effort good thank you
any other questions a platinum unrelated
or actual questions can be offered
on-site one last question in my opinion
this generation step could run on the
browser so you could just have a static
page put it on a CDN I don't know not
worry about anything for this model you
would be absolutely right
however in my enterprise version we'll
also have deep models obviously and then
so the main reason when I started all
this I kind of knew I needed some form
of back-end because I didn't know if
deep learning was going to win or not
and the main lesson for me is well is
this is a humorous project I'll be
having many and I just have a nice
scalable way for that but I don't have
to worry about costs so much I only have
to worry about DDoS attacks just just
only have to worry about these hours
attack
which put CloudFormation in front of it
it's fine
yeah either of us has it but but I've
heard over space is also great thanks
everyone thank you in 10
[Applause]